Ali
I warned you
forget
there is better ways to wake up someone
for Fajr and it's true if you woke
someone up for Fajr you will get the
same reward of them praying too but I
have something much better did you know
that if you yeah I'm talking to you
watching me now if you decided right now
sitting behind your computer to move
your fingers and press a few buttons
with the money that Allah has put in
your bank account when others have
nothing and if you decide to sponsor a
one or up to 10 people to learn how to
praise Salah for the first time in their
lives you will get the reward every
single time they pray not just Faja but
Isha did I forget asur yes Asser too
five times a day 35 times a week
140 times a month even their sunnan you
will get the same reward even if you die
and the reward will be on your scale oh
and I forgot to mention when they have
kids they will teach them just like your
family taught you on the day of judgment
you can have two thousand people praying
Salah for two to three hundred years
because your donation taught them how to
pray or you can choose to ignore this
video and never see that reward the
choice is yours click the button or the
link and donate now the choice is yours
click the button or the link and donate
now